MARCHESSAULT PUTS SHOT.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD JOB BY POWER
>> Butch: HE DROPPED THAT RIGHT
PAD DOWN.
>> Brendan: DOBSON TOT LOOKING.
IT GOES OFF THE SKATE.
ISLANDERS COMING BACK IN.
>> Butch: HE WANTS TO DUMP IT I
BACK THE LIGHTNING.
>> Butch: FIRST COUPLE OF SHIFTS
FOR THE HIM.
THESE TWO TEAMED PLAYED ONCE LE.
HOT AS OF LATE AS THEODORE
SCORES.
VEGAS TEAM AND A ONE-TIMER.
PARTIALLY SCREENED, I GETS IT.
STEPHENSON CAUGHT QUITE
QUICKLY.
>> Butch: THAT WAS A GOOD
CLUTTERBUCK.
OFF LIVE.
WATCH CIZIKAS BLUE
LINE THAT LOOK DOWN THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ACCCC
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING WORK
FOR THE
PLAYERS IN THIS HOCKEY GAME WITH
AT LEAST 900 GAMES OF NATIONAL .
PAGEAU'S GOT HIS STEC ON VEGAS.
THEODORE LETS IT FLY, AND THEY R
THE VEGAS TEAM.ICULARLY WITH THM
AS THEIRLEFT.
TWO
THEODORE WILL PULL T WAS A
GREAT MOVE.
SOROKIN C
THIS
MISSED THE NET BASICALLY.
HIT THE POST.>> Brendan: JONATH
MARCHESSAULT FOR VEGAS.
>> Butch: GOOD
IT.
>> Brendan: OLIVER WAHLSTRTRWAH
>> Butch: EXCEPTS HE SHOOTS
TH FOR